T first of all congratulations a big
victory for you against a very
unpleasant opponent tell us about your
initial feelings right
now oh definitely I feel very happy and
yeah she has been a problematic opponent
for me I lost two games to her in the
American Cup last year uh but of course
I'm very happy about this result and
she's a very good player so I'm
definitely feeling really good and it
felt quite smooth from our perspective
you definitely kept control and you're a
timing was very good as well you play
that move G4 kind of forcing her to go
for this queen trade at what point did
you feel like you're fully in control of
the
game oh when she went D5 at the end I me
I don't know what happened at the end
because like the whole time I was
thinking just don't lose control of the
position your upper pwn your her
position is completely ATT trous you
should be winning but then somehow her
Rook got to HB her Bishop got to F4 and
I just felt like maybe I lost control a
bit but um I mean I I didn't really have
time to really think about it too much
what how did happen but I think in even
in the final position if she doesn't
blunder I think her Rook on H1 is
actually quite misplaced and I can think
about sacking on F4 or I can after I
went B4 if she moves her Rook back I
thought I can just start pushing my PS
and I think here it should be maybe B5
even or A4 I don't know which way I want
to yeah no that that was I think here
already should be straightforward yeah
yeah did you feel like she lost patience
towards the end she didn't like
defending this unpleasant positions this
lost position in
fact
um yeah probably I mean things really
went bad for her from the opening I
think after Bishop F5 immediately I got
a huge initiative
and um I think the end game okay I know
the end game has to be very good for me
I think she supposed to take on F3 as
far as I remember but here my initiative
I think is very good because um
attempting to put something on F okay
this looks scary I think because I have
the G file but I don't know how
realistic my attack is but what we got
in the position I think is just supposed
to be very good for me again your timing
was very well this G4 move followed by
Knight to B3 I think this was an
important move as well just to ask
questions where is your queen going what
if she goes Queen to A4 and she tries to
keep the Queens on the board what was
your plan in this I
think I think her Knight is getting
trapped here somehow I mean she's losing
something here F the
yeah yeah I think I had something even
better she goes Knight G5 maybe you can
even take like H4 okay here I can h i
don't have H yes F4 I think is no no
this is very bad yeah F4 and then I just
G5 F5 I just push my pawns I think with
the queen on A4 my attack will be huge
here yeah yeah no very controlled game
congratulations tff guys any questions
for winner our congratulations T have
keep it up